e
G that is a union job you know you're
not allowed to move props on a
[Laughter]
set
all right I'm opening the work session
on retained House Bill 471 FN an act
relative to final disposition hearings
and divorce pre pre proceedings the
sponsor is with us represent sentive
yella and I let him know that while this
as he already knows while this isn't a
redo of the hearing uh there may be a
technical question or two and with the
leave of the chair we could ask him to
give us a sentence or two answer the
bill requires the court to schedule a
final disposition hearing upon the
issuance of temporary orders in a
divorce proceeding who would like to
start with some
comment
representative
McMahon thank you Mr chairman uh
relative to the uh statement here when I
was reading into this when was the uh
when a a final disposition hearing would
take place because when when you read
into the
methodology there's a timeline of a
competing interests on what would be uh
provided for supporting the issues in
play and then how much time that would
actually take to meet whenever this
hearing would would happen and that
that's I was wonder what my question on
this is is there is is there a inherent
timeline before uh temporary orders are
issued so that the the contested issues
would be
addressed before a final uh dis
disposition hearing would happen and
that's that's was this was getting
somewhat complicated and then the cost
of um the no cost identified but it's
referenced it's saying what's it take
for multiple hearings then when there's
competing interests here to meet a
deadline that they one or the or both
could not
meet so that's why I have I have a a
real I'm I'm not in support of what this
is offering because the information is
not complete on what the total impact
would be on our court system and the
appropriate process for adjudication of
uh the competing interests
thank
you that's a question
folks all right so I um in looking at
this I understand and I appreciate the
sponsor for being here today that's
super helpful I understand the idea of
wanting to have these because divorces
can be lengthy and you know it seems to
solve an issue by saying okay we
automatically have a date
however I disagree with just the idea of
having you know to schedule a date
immediately um first of all you can have
cases that should last I mean let's just
look at that if people come into a queue
and everybody automatically gets a date
you might have somebody come in that
maybe their divorce is very amicable it
should only take 30 days but because of
all these dates scheduled theirs is now
going to take 3 years so the pressure
that this would put on the court reports
and even saying you know we have a date
but it can change some of those changes
if you have to have a set date you could
you don't change until like the day
before we did have the courts in here
and they specified how complicated that
would be so while I think this is
looking
to um solve a little problem it's going
to cause a much much bigger problem in a
much much bigger bottleneck for our
courts so I would be opposed to this
bill
thank
you representative ball this is informal
we kind of KN okay thank you chairman
paron for nodding to me
yes um I remember when we spoke that
about this bill um in committee and my
concern was that it's taking way too
long to get the final disposition dates
when people are ready to move forward
and that people were just looking to be
put in the queue so that they would
would not be working on being amicable
and coming up with um their parenting
plans and doing all the things that they
need to do to work together and then say
okay we need our final date and find out
they're going to get scheduled a year
out that just opens the door for more
animosity and more frustration and
people want to get on with their lives
and I I think that if we schedule a date
or the court schedules a date there's
nothing to say that that date can't then
be said we don't need the date or we
we're going to need to push it out to an
unforeseen and then you have no date but
for those um cases where it's moving
along everything is amicable everybody
knows um how things are going to end
they do need to have a date they need to
know when
um when they're going to be able to move
on with their life and how they can
schedule um
post uh
divorce
I representative long thank you Mr
chairman um so yeah I I have I have the
same issues with uh I I look at this as
a creating more conflict now that
there's a competing interest uh there's
a date that they have to meet I could
blame I could blame the other party for
not meeting that date um and as far as
pushing it
out I I'm thinking when I read this I'm
thinking that I could push out the date
but I have to give another
date um I just can't push it out
indefinitely I I have to give a d a
final disposition so it was going to be
in September we see that's not going to
happen uh do I put it in
December uh do I put it in January so so
uh pushing it out
is
every every case needs a final uh
disposition so I I I'm over the opinion
that this will
create uh more of a conflict it opens
the door for more of a conflict so I'm
I'm oppos
is as I think we've been learning
um especially those of us who have also
been working on the special committee on
the court each case has its own issues
and we may not know how it's going to
end um for some time
similarly there are
emergencies and they take precedence and
if you had the emergency you would want
it to so the date is set and we're now
at that date and there's three or four
emergency orders that have to be written
and hearings that have to be done and at
the end of the day we haven't gotten to
this so now it has to go out further uh
one one of the things that we have
learned in terms of
calendar is until recent well no even
now we don't have enough
judges and the report there was a
wonderful
report that looked at cases based on the
average amount of time in the past they
would just listed how many cases but
then they looked at okay X percentage of
divorce cases take this long X
percentage of that kind of divorce case
really take much further and they came
up with a statement that we need over 20
more
judges in order to honor what is behind
all of the um bills that we've received
uh they understand it and we gave them
seven in the new budget which isn't 20
some odd but it is not nothing and uh I
know the chairman of Finance is already
prepared to give us another another
batch next time and he understands why
so not enough judges uh okay pick a date
what
judge is going to be able to to do this
we don't have enough also what happens
if one or another party churns that's a
stock broker term but it means just
flooding with more motions flooding with
demanding more evidence The Rules of
Evidence great book if you haven't read
it four times I commend it to you um
there is something in here that says if
a judge believes that the motion to
accept another bit of evidence does not
enhance the
case the judge May refuse to admit that
piece of evidence and and it's so that
people will stop petition petition
evidence do this do this do that uh
which some parties do and with that in
hand um how can you possibly know when
you're going to come to something final
if these petitions keep coming in now
we've got people who want to say if
somebody offers a piece of evidence it
shall be received that's going to do a
terrible thing to schedule on the other
hand we've got people who are angry
because the judge is not refusing that
piece of evidence and you know I think
the Rules of Evidence book tries to to
get a good balance in there so this in
other words this is complicated as we've
all been saying um I will say this
though that the uh Judiciary is paying a
lot of attention to Children and Family
Law bills having to do with court
process and with the discussions we're
having in the special committee on the
Family Division of the Circuit Court
they're paying attention and it's
interesting some of the things that
we've been disc discussing in the
special committee they're already
starting to work on they're already
getting ready to send out um bids for
people companies who will come in and
work on training issues this is
something we brought up they caught on
and I'm willing to say that um they're
paying attention to the idea of setting
some final dates as best they can given
all the exigencies they're working on
I think they're paying
attention so for that reason I would
also say this is this is very well
intended I think we understand uh why uh
somebody would want a date set um but
I'm going to have to join people and and
say
no so with that would somebody like to
make a motion or if we're not if we're
finished our discussion would somebody
body like to make a
motion representative Greg I'll make a
motion that we recommend to the full
committee that this be um itl okay do I
have a
second
second that was a flat dead tie in which
case them Republican evil yeah you get
the next one that's why I was waiting I
know I never like like long the waight
so
the motion is made itl on House Bill 471
FN relative to final disposition
hearings and divorce pre pre
proceedings and um I will call the role
uh the motion is itl representative
McMahon yes representative
ball representative long yes
representative Greg yes and the chair
says yes so the decision
itl is 4 to one and
uh I would say to the prime sponsor um
we've
given we we understand but there's some
more work that needs to be done I just
encourage you to come back with it based
on some of the things we've tried to to
speak into this today but thank you and
thank you for coming
you may make a comment representative
ball I just wanted to comment that you
um mentioned that we had hired some new
attorneys uh Jud not attorney judges I'm
sorry that we're going to be adding
those and I would like um to make the
comment that we have reached out to
um to the courts and to the Department
of Education and they are now working uh
in tandem to hire and fill the position
for the 40 openings in the clerical so
hopefully some of the backlog will take
um will take care of that they're going
to be working through the uh learn
everywhere program and um we'll see how
that goes that's something that we just
put them together to to see if they
could figure something out good job
thank
you uh
no no you have no standing so with that
we conclude the um work group on House
Bill
yeah we've already
rained we were ained it
and